let's talk about how you develop them to
then you come up with it from your own
inspiration not who are you going to
target to how many women between the
sage you're going to watch it right so
even though his vampire sure but it was
you know vampire mafia is just too I
mean the Mafia thing is always a fun
world bad guys are just fun and it's
it's a fun world and I base some of it
on the state of organized crime in
Boston the late eighties after the FBI
had done a sweep of the patriarchal
family through wiretaps there was a big
battle team for turf essentially like
who owned what and and so I the
off-screen logic to vampire mob was that
was the world that was the state of this
world and so as I cooked it it actually
the first place vampire mob was it was a
short play that was performed at the
Russell Group theater in Santa Monica
even think of doing for nine years
called the LA cafe plays were the third
Sunday of every month vibrators me at
nine o'clock in the morning they throw
10 envelopes on the floor and we picked
them up and pull them out there's two
head shots with no resume that's our
cast I'm given a theme we have four
hours great of play we're done at one
start printing it goes to the casting
director and assistant director they
rehearse it until seven-thirty that's
the first performance and then they do
another show at nine so I've written
about twenty six or seven of those plays
and vampire mob was the first long and
it was one of those things that like if
you take a screenwriting class they will
tell you some teachers will say well
let's take your characters grocery
shopping just to see what they do see
how they interact with the world and the
only time you do those when you're in
class because no one's going to do that
I'll let me do way some time doing that
but writing that play really let me know
a bunch of stuff about the character and
even at that point Don a different
name he was a mafia guy he wasn't a hit
man yet there was some inference but it
was about his character meeting the
person to become a vampire it was
something I never wanted to shoot i
wanted to the kind of classic
screenwriting thing come in as late as
possible leave as early as possible in a
scene I wanted to come in or worried
before the hit the fan and I didn't
want all that set up so by minute three
of the first episode we already have
with conflict as we already know a bunch
of things so the way i right and right
now i'm writing third season and i have
piles of legal pads and I just jam I
just any no rules anything that comes
into my head about any character any
line any seam and I just start writing
these little things down and when I
wrote the second season I went to the
first season legal pad stuff that I've
written and it was one little spoiler
there's one little thing that I had that
Don the main character was a hit man had
killed another character's father and
she didn't know it and that was always
something that was in the biography if
it's only I knew that nobody else to do
that but it was in those notes and in
looking through essentially the
character bios I mean I don't get that I
right kind of like who they are what are
they about what do they want that kind
of thing but once I know enough about
the characters then I can go well here's
what this character wants and here's
what this character wants in this world
what's to stop each of these characters
from getting what they want and that's
when plot and all the other stuff for me
comes about so it's really like if
you're a painter maybe you sketch and
you kind of figure stuff out first and
then you start hitting the canvas for me
the legal pads are just play pure-play
it's a playground right anything you
want I write stuff I won't end up using
a right stuff that I do
I write out whole scenes sometimes I'll
just bullet stuff and then once I have
it cooking I my rule I sort of have my
rules for web series I have tried to
have three locations per episode I try
to end with some kind of conflict which
is pretty classic episodic writing that
you what happens next episode like you
want to end at a point that won't make
you think well I want to watch them
except so but that will happen next you
well that's what I want and I always
write each episode as an individual file
I never read the whole script right
episode 1 is 1 file a great episode 2
and they never come together and so I
have them all written part of that is a
complete psychology trick because i'm
not writing a long script just bring
these little things shooting these
little things and then when you put them
all together wow that's a lot of
and the first season was a 33-page
script the second season was an 82 page
script when they were put all together
and I write very sparse lots of light
and I will in post-production I'll cut
stuff out I have cut lines out of
rearrange stuff I now understand much
more about getting rewritten having
written and shot stuff but it's those
are kind of my structurally my rules so
then what I'll do is I'll have episode 1
i'll have a one two three those are the
three kind of main story points of each
episode like i try to have like you know
Don finds out that Frank gets out of
jail in this episode of his wife has
this reaction to this and then once I
have a bare bones and I know where it's
going now sit down and and actually
write the script so I kind of like
Duke a free-form jam on a legal pad kind
of cook the characters pick the story
come up with some ideas and then give a
little structure to each episode so a
very loose outline like one sentence and
then that gives me enough play because I
don't want to have everything so planned
out nothing can happen when I'm writing
and not all sit down and actually write
the dialogue and write the scenes and a
nap because I know where I'm going I
know that I need to end by this so it
makes me recognize you know I can't
write a five-page scene because I want
that kind of time with season three so
far the episodes are going to be a long
do you write it home do you find
yourself getting too distracted there do
you go to a coffee shop do you know i'm
not i'm not i tried to be a coffee shop
writer um i always need to write on a
laptop some of that is pure cycle I it's
like I'm just a little laptop there's
just something about the Sun go my desk
mm-hmm seems like let me do a
spreadsheet yes just something about it
doesn't seem it just seems closer to God
like handwriting and a bell laptop
anywhere in bed on the couch if I do if
I'm in a public when I write cafe plays
I'm in a we all meet at a cafe to write
it at the back on Broadway on Broadway
in Santa Monica I have headphones on and
I always listen to music that I know
really well and I always sent to Fats
Waller I've let's know a lot of fats
waller when I write because it occupies
the part of my brain that can think of
something to do other than writing I
find that it's just like that part of my
brain that's like it we should go for a
walk maybe what about another protocol
instead it's just like that's occupied
and I'm just writing and and it creates
this little fantasy world and that's the
way I look at writing this leg I don't
believe in writer's block it doesn't
exist it's and it's just some
ideas take a little longer but to have
this kind of
I'm just playing he's all play like it's
got to be fun it's not fun why am i
doing I'm writing oh who wants to do
that I'm not getting paid this is gonna
take everything out of me when I shoot
this I'm playing I'm wreck this is going
to be so much fun for these actors
that's the other thing to keep in mind
is like I keep the actors in mind when
I'm writing like because I've I pay
money to sag for some reason I don't act
anymore but I have acted it's so much
fun to be handed something and go all
this is gonna be so much fun to do
because when I'm writing it it's the
same thing oh this could be so much fun
to do today ah so that those are sort of
my loose my loose even if I'm writing a
feature it's the same it's the same
process it's just a different structure
but it's got to be fun
you